if Hunter was living there if he  actually was you know why there's no  visitor logged because the list of  hookers would be too long they'd just be  like we got we got it we got destiny  Laquisha Pink Panther Lotus is a good  stripper name Ian do you know something  candy don't leave candy candy Agnes yeah  she's an old one and how many of them  are like Fang Fang like Russia you know  not Russian or Chinese spies I guarantee  you some of them are probably spies Joe  walks in and Hunter's got like two  Russian women on his arms and he's  sunglasses and he's smoking a joint and  he's like who are these should see  Scarlet yeah I don't know spies I guess  how did they get past security what  security there's no logs there's no  security